[Music]
okay guys so uh when i was doing
research for the jk news search first i
stumbled across
an article that a news article that i
was like oh this is gonna be very
interesting and it is it is this ben
affleck is finally opening up about his
biggest regret what is it he has rad
grant was it j-lo j-lo was his biggest
regret huh we're going to find out
together i think it was daredevil
together it's a video well no no we have
to we have we have to go through it all
is he fighting with j.lo so here he is
there's marriage and challenges
that's jennifer garner yeah jennifer
garner okay so we got his biggest regret
was dating two jennifers dude doesn't
that suck that like people are taking
pictures of you while you're having a
very big argument with your wife not
really if it makes you money oh that's
true at least paparazzi but you think
that's what's on his mind right now
this part's about how
you know they were one of hollywood's
hottest couples but then all that came
to a halt it was rumored that he was
cheating with the nanny how fine was a
nanny though so to find out we have to
click next oh my god it's one of these
stupid things what's stupid
news
dude because some nannies are hot okay
so now
that's a hot nanny it wasn't exactly
love at first sight was it
oh
she's the villain in this i guess she's
jafar who's that weird looking dude
how come that guy's asian glow oh i
don't know we have to click next i don't
know hold on
they always they're so good
they're letting you down with all the
ads and the misclicks this is the news
man
i found this on the news site okay okay
okay
together again affleck and garner
crossed each other's paths again in 2002
when they co-starred in daredevil
everyone remembers that
i love this daredevil i like to take my
i like to take my mouse i like to touch
on his pee pee a little bit
touch on her boobies a little bit yeah
yeah if you don't do this at home you
always do it dude okay so this isn't
about his greatest regret yet so we're
going to click next
yeah okay so
dinner dates from 2001 2005
john favreau had a show called dinner
for five ever remembers that
oh awareness by slide four out of eighty
this is the news they were on there
together so this doesn't really say
anything about his greatest regret so
we're gonna damn it they got us again
it's part of the build up you guys you
guys need the whole story for the
biggest regrets bart's face looks
actually interesting i am
like the the url and type in like 70 or
80 in the very end to try to get to the
very end you know oh what because i i
just want to see what the the result is
[Laughter]
timothy
all right
that's all we know from this one we
gotta click next unfortunately
not really seeing where his greatest
regret is yeah varner's side of the
story though very important it's that
weird guy again who the [ __ ] is that
weird guy no this weird guy that always
shows up
so it's probably timothy
um
something about
ah nothing nothing involving them okay
not a mention of affleck nothing here we
go affleck and j.lo oh
juicy stuff have you seen her at the
[ __ ] all her she was looking fire at
the megala dude she wanted megan fox the
vmas
no nobody was nobody i don't know but
that doctor
50
and i've been to that guy's store he's
out here in hollywood he makes nick okay
man he has a hat store wow
he made that hat for her so finally i
guess garner and the other guy
they were married then they got divorced
now all of a sudden affleck was still
engaged to jennifer lopez
and then
this is the way the regret comes in this
is where the regret come up nope
wait how is jennifer lopez and bobby lee
the same age no she's older than bobby
lee flip is like 60 isn't she you heard
it here you're like 50 something yeah i
think he's 54.
54.
wait is bobby lee the next slide
ben affleck goes to bob lee stand-up
show oh that's not the regret yet keep
going okay this this one
affleck and garner didn't show up
holding hands yet um so yeah we're going
to conclude we're not quitting who's
that uh some guy she was with at a ball
game that was ben affleck
oh was it
okay so research down here garner and
affleck were determined uh they were
kissing in public so he cheated on jello
with her i think he they broke up i
think they broke up and then these two
got together
after daredevil time paparat's so
annoying huh they're everywhere i
paparazzi myself and leaked my own
photos because i could make a lot of
money being paparazzi if i was a
celebrity that's like how spiderman
takes pieces of himself yeah and sells
them to do the doodles
very
very very smart move by the way by him
okay so now they're together this is a
nice looking good they're getting
coffees and things are good
um i don't know what this has to do with
this biggest regret yeah i forgot to
click next god damn it all right damn
they got us huh this is the news but
every single time you click it we they
get an ad yeah is that what's going on
they got our cookies they get money that
way guys it's like a 10 cents per click
i hope so we just gave them a dollar
well so you're saying that this has less
less integrity than the regular news
where if you click it they get ads too
i think it's the same i never said that
i'm just saying that i think they're
struggling and they need help that's why
we're giving them donations every time
we click i just want to know what has
been what
what's this publication called yeah
that's the biggest regret this is called
bride's blush there we go where's the
biggest regret i need to know what kind
of content is what i'm saying dude all
right it's a legitimate source this is a
source okay what are you going to do
trust wikipedia
popping up at this point well that's
cause i have it up in brave browser kind
of oh okay yeah that that's the secret
right here what i'm saying brave
brothers is the [ __ ] so they're back
together again so now they um if i can
find it fascinating yeah it looks like
they're
they're together they're back together
here okay all right but um but no
regrets are you guys big fans of alias
the tv regret okay
okay here we go
they had a baby oh they had a girl
did they adopt her because she's not
even a baby a seven year old i guess
they're not she's not even a baby this
article is skipping a lot i looked up
the biggest regret for ben affleck i'm
gonna see if i can find it faster than
you let's see if you do let's see if you
do i doubt you another girl are they
trying to trick us like hey that's the
you thought this was the regret having
kids but it's not well that could be
what it is they're both adopted they
didn't have biological kids one more
time got it the actor said the biggest
regret of my life is this divorce shame
is really toxic there's no positive
byproduct of shame it is just a toxic
and hideous feeling of low self-esteem
well why couldn't they just say if we
could just get to that yeah at the first
slide the build up dude it was divorced
how many more do we have to go through
they're painting the picture of a
beautiful marriage and then divorce you
know 147.
oh my god what's up 147 when you were
researching this article you didn't make
it to the end did you i made it oh dude
i read the whole thing the writer is
veronica carnell was it worth the wait i
you know i can't tell because he already
spoiled it so
you're supposed to discover this stuff
together as friends but then you know we
got a guy here who's going to take it
away from us hey man you're really
sitting in a bearish market there for a
while
his biggest regret is divorce i think it
oh here it is
i actually did find it okay okay hold on
his biggest regret well it seems like he
was jennifer garner's biggest regret it
was a divorce for him
we don't know well that was jennifer
garner's no that was ben really because
i thought he said it was like she was
saying that uh it was the shame is toxic
because those sound like feminine words
well ben affleck oh okay no he's not
matt damon i just find it but he is from
bastion fast he said he's ashamed for
the divorce because so the biggest
regret of my life is this divorce shame
is really toxic so he was uh maybe the
shame was the byproduct of divorce yeah
is it because he cheated he was sleeping
with the nanny he [ __ ] the nanny was
that confirmed do they have a picture of
her do they have a picture of the nanny
i think so yeah
google uh ben affleck's nanny
i need to know if it was worth it or not
click's nanny oh dude worth it
that's so that's not there's no way ben
affleck's fine ass nanny dude how do you
hire this nanny if i am jennifer gardner
i'm going no ben we're not hiring that's
correct come on she's not a nanny bro oh
she's a nanny she's a real estate agent
no i know i think i've also seen her on
millhunter.com yeah yeah i think i need
a nanny now
christine something i think i need nanny
dude i'll be your nanny dude no no no no
i want a nanny like that one she looks
like she's skilled with kids bro i'm way
better
than she is i believe anything you say
that she looks like she's good at
vacuuming how come there's no mail nanny
man we don't we don't want mail nanny
yeah mannys are out there for boys
filipino dudes would you are they i
think so manny pacquiao is that what it
is
that's male 1 that's his post boxing
career he becomes male manny anybody
need a money
i'll take care of your babies see this
way you can't
benefit's name that's the same lady
without sunglasses on maybe because he
forgot she has too many things on her
face because he was like oh my god
you're taking care of my kids you're my
wife oh whoops no you're not oh i see
you're doing paternal things
it's getting some juice oh no he just
forgot who his wife was because he's
like wait you're not my wife how come
you're taking care of my kids this is
every movie though this is every movie
the guy gets a nanny
every porno movie yeah that's true
that's true what's that movie he did
it's a similar story gone girl a gong
girl it's basically gone girl
that should have been his greatest
regret but i guess it wasn't it's either
a nanny or babysitter you didn't like
gone girl wow gone girl oh wait i was
thinking of gee lee geology
another g name gone girl is the one
where the wife suspects him is cheating
because he is cheating so she plans her
whole death and frames him so she's
alive oh yeah rosamund pike
right yeah
do you ever think like geo can pull that
off i think if anyone could do it as gio
yeah probably can jio's probably gonna
be really good at that that sucks dude
i'm sorry paint yourself in a corner
didn't you dude i like the part where
she ordered like a [ __ ] ton of
playstation [ __ ] and had it in the shed
or whatever and then he walks in there
and he's like oh [ __ ] yeah on his credit
card on his credit card that's a good
move because it looks like he's he's
like setting up for life without her and
[ __ ] dude yeah that's genius so smart
that is genius and she took her own
blood the best part was the kitchen cut
herself and put blood all over the
kitchen and cleaned it to a max but left
just enough for the cops to find so good
[ __ ] geo's gonna [ __ ] you over
[Music]
you